Ця молодь танцює за зміни в країні
У техноклубі "Хіді"
йдеться не лише про музику
а й про боротьбу проти дискримінації гомосексуалів
Клубне життя символізує свободу
у консервативній кавказькій країні
Клубна культура в Грузії
розвивається дуже швидко
але потрібен час, щоб змінився менталітет людей
які багато років вважали, що люди як ми - вороги
що ми дивні і не заслуговуємо на те
щоб бути частиною цього суспільства
Цей менталітет повинен змінитися
і ми намагаємося його змінити
З травня цього року танці
стали політичним меседжем
Тоді озброєна поліція увірвалася
у два відомі нічні клуби
Café Gallery та "Бассіані"
під приводом пошуку наркодилерів
Після цього сотні людей вийшли на протести
і танцювали
Проти жорстокості поліції та за ліберальні цінності
Активіст Леван Беріанідзе
регулярно організовує вечірки для гомосексуалів
у клубі "Бассіані"
Він каже, що проти представників ЛГБТ-спільноти
часто спрямовані ненависть та насильство
Тому ця спільнота була вагомою частиною протесту
ЛГБТ-спільнота та інші меншини
знають "Бассіані" як надійне місце
Там вони відчувають солідарність,
рівність та свободу
якої так мало за межами клубної сцени
Грузія дуже консервативна
І обшуки в клубах -
своєрідна загроза їхньому осередку
У Грузії консервативні цінності
та православна церква
мають велику вагу
Багато націоналістичних груп
роками борються за політичний вплив у країні
Гія Коркоташвілі - музикант
та один із засновників ультранаціоналістичного руху "Грузинський марш"
Він виступає проти імміграції
та за так звані традиційні сімейні цінності
Коркоташвілі вважає, що Грузія втрачає свою національну ідентичність
через західний лібералізм
Куди ми прагнемо, куди ми вриваємося?
Куди? Там темрява
і ми нічого не бачимо
І нині в Грузії говорять про європейську країну
Це абсурд. Яка європейська країна?
Це кавказька країна!
Один із представників "Грузинського маршу"
балотується на президентських виборах,
що відбудуться в жовтні
Утім, хто насправді визначатиме майбутнє Грузії
ще незрозуміло
Поки що різні групи та покоління
тягнуть країну в різних напрямках